bienvenido a esta meditación
supongo que si estás escuchando esto es
porque estás por presentar una prueba o
examen importante pues ese es el título
de esta meditación la palabra meditación
puede evocar diferentes ideas a
diferentes personas pero realmente es
una forma de poder observar nuestros
pensamientos y quizá aquietar los de
algún modo que nos haga sentir un poco
más ligeros un poco más tranquilos un
poco más felices y menos estresados o
ansiosos frecuentemente esto nos ayuda a
hacer mejor las cosas que nos estresa
van en un principio vamos a comenzar lo
primero en lo que siempre hago énfasis y
algo que tomo en cuenta cuando medito es
que la postura la respiración y el
entorno pueden ser muy importantes
encuentra un lugar agradable en el que
te puedas sentar idealmente en silencio
o al menos donde el sonido no te moleste
y siéntate tan erguido como te sea
posible
si hay un poco de ruido alrededor no
permitas que te moleste o te irrita sólo
acéptalo es el universo haciendo sus
sonidos es algo que puedes observar es
incluso un poco gracioso y cuando
aceptas tu entorno ya sea lo que te
rodea o incluso alguna sensación en tu
cuerpo comienza a respirar un poco más
profundo
y un poco más lento que como lo estabas
haciendo antes de empezar esta
meditación
inhala
sostén la y exhala
tú puedes establecer tu propio ritmo
para inhalar
y exhalar
pero intenta hacerlo un poco más
profundo
y un poco más lento
cuando hago esto me gusta sentarme
erguido normalmente en una silla y poner
mis manos con las palmas hacia arriba
sobre mis muslos pero puedes hacerlo de
la manera que te resulte más cómoda
otra cosa que te quiero pedir y que
puede parecer poco natural es forzar una
sonrisa intenta que sea lo más real
posible pero si tienes que forzarla
hazlo lo que he encontrado es que
obviamente cuando estamos felices
tendemos a sonreír pero también puedes
hacer que suceda a la inversa que forzar
una sonrisa te haga sentir un poco mejor
un poco más positivo intenta mantener
esa sonrisa en tu cara durante toda la
meditación
idealmente también después de la
meditación no tiene que ser una sonrisa
falsa puede ser solamente una sonrisa
sutil si así quieres pero algo que te
haga sentir un poco mejor
así continúa inhalando
y exhalando
si aún no has cerrado los ojos hazlo
ahora suavemente
y antes de que te deje un momento para
estar contigo mismo en silencio para
observar y quizás aquietar tus
pensamientos te daré unas ideas en las
que puedes pensar
buena parte del estrés que produce un
examen proviene de identificarse con el
resultado
nos quedamos atrapados en qué tal si no
lo hago bien o necesito hacerlo bien o
lo voy a hacer tan impresionantemente
bien que me van a suceder cosas
maravillosas en la vida
el problema de apegarse el resultado es
que el resultado puede o puede no
suceder
todo a eso que le temes puede o puede no
pasar
todas estas expectativas pueden o no
cumplirse y cuando te identificas con
eso y no sucede bueno
puede haber una ligera desconexión entre
la realidad y tú y esta es una de las
principales razones de infelicidad
cuando la realidad no funciona del modo
en que la gente quiere en cambio te
puedes identificar un poco más con el
proceso con la aventura y decir mira
tengo este examen que presentar y voy a
dar lo mejor de mí voy a trabajar para
prepararme y voy a disfrutar ese trabajo
soy un ser sintiente en este planeta
en este misterio que llamamos vida y
puedo participar en este desafío que
representa el examen puedes disfrutar de
estos momentos antes de que te des
cuenta
vas a ser mucho mayor y vas a rememorar
este momento de tu vida y te vas a reír
de ti mismo porque no lo disfrute más
ahora con la idea de enfocarse en la
aventura de la preparación te voy a
ofrecer otra visualización que encuentro
muy útil
imagina que tu subconsciente es un
enorme océano y que tu conciencia la
parte que piensa para sí mismo
aquí estoy soy un tipo de percepción
pura intentando observar y darle sentido
el universo es un cielo claro y lleno de
luz
la mayoría de nosotros funcionan en la
superficie de ese océano casi todo el
tiempo
están todos estos pensamientos
aleatorios que surgen de ese océano
o las que se rompen en nuestra
conciencia
para algunos de ustedes pueden ser
pensamientos reflexiones sobre cómo
estás para este examen o sobre las
consecuencias de hacerlo bien o mal
o pueden ser otras cosas como algo que
sucede en tu vida social o tareas que
tienes pendientes o cosas de un ámbito
más amplio que te preocupe
pero
uno de los objetivos de la meditación es
darse cuenta de que esos pensamientos
que están en la superficie de tu
subconsciente no son tú
y que de hecho puedes elevarte por
encima de ellos elevarte sobre la
superficie de ese océano
imagínate como una conciencia pura
elevándose sobre esa superficie y
percatándose de que todos esos
pensamientos que están aleteando
chapoteando contra tu percepción pura tu
conciencia no tienen que hacerlo
ahora estás encima de ellos y solo hay
unas cuantas gotas que de vez en cuando
te pueden hacer sonreír y puedes
eliminar y puedes mirar hacia abajo a la
superficie de ese océano y a la
distancia esos pensamientos no parecen
ser tan importantes
y conforme mires desde arriba esos
pensamientos vas a comenzar a apreciar
que van a volverse más lentos
el océano comenzará a quitarse un poco
y mientras sigues inhalando
y exhalando
allí estás
justo en el cielo soleado sobre el
océano
tú eres ese cielo soleado sobre ese
océano que este subconsciente
tú eres esa luz solar pura
y con esa idea en mente te daré un
minuto de silencio para que solamente
nahles iec sales
y experimenté regocijo en esa luz en la
que estás
experimenta gozo por no dejarse atrapar
por esos pensamientos si tu mente
deambula si tu conciencia regresa a la
superficie de ese océano y comienza a
agitarse no hay razón para preocuparse
sólo recuerda sonrió un poco y di o me
perdí en el océano de nuevo en las olas
de la superficie
voy a elevarme de nuevo
regresaré en aproximadamente un minuto
muy bien
estamos de regreso
continúa inhalando
y exhalando
espero que hayas experimentado aunque
sea un poco de quietud
incluso si fueron solo cinco o diez
segundos
la experiencia de saber que tú no eres
tus pensamientos de saber que puedes
observar tus pensamientos y que puede
haber momentos en tu vida en que te
liberas de tus pensamientos
ahora que estamos terminando esta
meditación conserva un par de ideas en
tu cabeza
recuerda no enfocarte en el resultado
sino en el proceso y disfrútalo
esa sonrisa que espero que siga en tu
rostro mantenla todo el tiempo mientras
te preparas mantenla mientras presentas
esa prueba o examen del tipo que sea
y si puedes intenta tomar un poco de tu
tiempo todos los días no importa si es 1
2 o 3 minutos en el que puedas sentarte
en silencio con una buena postura y
respirar lenta y profundamente con una
sonrisa en tu rostro y elevarte sobre
tus pensamientos
estoy seguro de que no sólo vas a
disfrutar esta experiencia sino que vas
a dar lo mejor de ti en ese examen
y que con el paso del tiempo te vas a
dar cuenta de que ese examen no era tan
importante
y muchas cosas en nuestra vida que en su
momento parecen ser realmente
importantes con un poco de distancia en
tiempo y espacio resulta que no lo son
si aún no lo has hecho te invito a que a
tu propio ritmo mientras continúa
sonriendo e inhalando y exhalando
profundamente abras tus ojos
suavemente y disfrutes esta aventura
este misterio que llamamos vida